You might want to take
a step back there, Captain.
I'm sorry.
I know I'm staring a lot.
Huge fan. Huge fan.
Been following your career
for quite a while now.
Visual tower,
this is Shuttle Marmota
approaching docking bay four.
Closing the blast shields.
- Shuttle Marmota,
you're clear to dock.
- Yeah. Copy you.
Truth be told,
we couldn't afford
to show that anyway,
but, yeah,
don't get me wrong.
I know exactly
where we're heading.
Check it out.
We're gonna land in five--
( clanking, hissing )
Captain, we're here early.
I gotta say, it's an honor.
I was thinking maybe
we could hang out or something?
Go get a coffee.
But, you know, beer's cool.
( alarm buzzing )
Welcome aboard
the Invincible II, Captain.
Glad to have you here.
Took you long enough.
But let me give you
the grand tour before we embark.
- This is my pride and joy.
- No!
My baby.
Well, your baby, I guess, now.
But I made her,
and a baby will always
remember her father.
Computer: Bio-scan.
Welcome aboard, Captain,
and head engineer.
Prepare for sterilization.
First stop, the warp core,
the heart and soul of the ship.
Still not 100% sure
how it works,
but you don't need to know
how something works
in order to use it.
And when we found it again,
it passed every safety test
with flying colors.
- It's not gonna be
like last time. Oh, no.
- Aah! My eyes!
This time the Invincible
is finally gonna live up
to her name.
But just in case,
I built in a special precaution.
If anything goes wrong,
we can detonate these explosives
and separate the warp core
from the rest of the ship.
( imitates explosion )
I've yet to meet a problem
that can't be solved
with explosives.
And speaking of explosives,
the main reactor!
It turns out you pretty much
need the power of a star
to tear open a wormhole,
so a star I built.
Built like a tank, too.
Captain. Burt.
- Yep.
- That's Burt.
He makes sure that
the ship don't go boom.
- Next up is Cryo. Oh, hey.
- Hey, Mark.
The colonists are prepped,
stable, and ready for transit.
Systems are working
at 110%, too,
which is a little weird,
but overkill never hurts.
- Trust me.
- Woman: Hello!
You do not want to be awake
when the warp core hits the gas.
Woman:
I think I'm supposed
to be asleep,
but I don't think I am.
- CC.
- Asshat.
Captain, all colonists
are prepped and stable.
100,000 souls
ready for a new life.
- Let's get them there safe.
- Oh, don't worry.
before they know it,
they're gonna wake up
to the sight
of a brand new planet
with a fresh cup of coffee
in their hands.
Why don't you give them
more windows to look through?
Well, maybe I will!
Maybe then someone might
appreciate the aesthetics.
Besides, what could go wrong
with a crew like this?
ADS is good to go.
Don't worry, Captain.
No asteroid's getting by me.
You can count on that.
- ( PA chatter )
- ( overlapping chatter )
Computer: Requesting
additional personnel.
Hey, watch it!
Oh, my God, I'm so--
Oh, no. Captain, I'm falling!
Catch me! Aah!
( bones crack )
Navigation is online,
Captain.
Engines are looking good,
Life support is online,
unless it's not,
and then we wouldn't know
until we passed out.
Seems fine.
Everything is accounted for.
We're ready to see
our new home.
All that's left now...
...is for you to say the word.
Try not to get them
too excited, Captain.
I know how your speeches
can get people riled up.
( clears throat )
( coughing )
Computer:
Warp core engaged.
( alarm blaring )
Wormhole opening
in 30 seconds.
All personnel report
to your assigned cryo-pod.
Ah, it's all right, Captain.
I'm sure you'll make a great
speech once we get there.
( mumbling )
Oh, and I forgot to mention,
it's not a problem, of course,
but just before you go to sleep,
be absolutely sure, do not--
Computer:
Wormhole opening
in ten, nine, eight,
seven, six-- error.
Error, error, error,
error, error, error, error.
Wormhole opening
in three, two--
Voice:
A software update
is available.
Would you like to restart
to apply this update?
( overlapping voices )
Don't give up.
Voice:
Software update complete.
Computer:
Good morning, Captain.
We are currently ERROR years
into our journey.
Coffee is en route.
Current ship status
is absolutely catastrophic.
Initializing emergency
Wakey-Wakey Protocol.
( alarms blaring )
- ( explosion )
- Reviving head engineer.
( grunting )
Captain,
what the hell is-- aah!
Hull breach detected.
Sealing bulkhead.
Fire on the bridge.
Error.
Life support systems failing.
Error. Automatic Fire
Suppression System offline.
Error.
Fail-safes offline.